it all began to unravel when the US
president picked up his phone in July a
call to the president of Ukraine what
was said enough for a whistleblower to
file a complaint that made it to
Congress the allegation was that Trump
was holding hundreds of millions of
dollars in military aid meant for
Ukraine which was fighting off Russian
aggression until the Ukrainian president
promised to investigate Trump's
potential political rival former US Vice
President Joe Biden and his son hunter
who had worked in Ukraine in damage
control mode the White House released
notes from the call it did more damage
because as the notes point out as the
Ukrainian president is promising to buy
more US missiles
Trump responds I would like you to do us
a favor though he goes on to ask for
investigations into a debunked
conspiracy theory about the election and
later brings up the Biden's the
President must be held accountable no
one is above the law
that's when Democrats announced an
impeachment inquiry would begin the
White House refused to cooperate but
several career diplomats came forward
anyway they testified under oath that it
all really happened Colonel Alexander
bin Minh listened to the call and later
reported it to White House lawyers it is
improper for the President of the United
States to demand a foreign government
investigate a US citizen and a political
opponent the former US ambassador to
Ukraine testified that she was removed
from her position because she wanted to
fight corruption so the president's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani pushed to
get her removed when our anti-corruption
efforts got in the way of a desire for
profit or power Ukrainians who prefer to
play by the old corrupt rules sought to
remove me what continues to amaze me is
that they found Americans willing to
partner with them and working together
they apparently succeeded in
orchestrating the removal of a US
ambassador others described a small
group of people chosen by the President
as running a kind of shadow bat-channel
US policy in Ukraine it became clear to
me that Giuliani's efforts to gin up
politically motivated investigations
we're now infecting u.s. engagement with
Ukraine
leveraging president solinsky's desire
for a White House meeting to withhold
that assistance for no good reason other
than help with the political campaign
made no sense it was it was
counterproductive to all of what we had
been trying to do it was illogical it
could not be explained it was crazy
Trump meeting was going to happen and
then came the surprising testimony from
ambassador Gordon Sunland who changed
his testimony from what he first told
Congress was there a quid pro quo as I
testified previously with regard to the
requested White House call and the White
House meeting the answer is yes Sunland
was a donor to the president's
inauguration rewarded with an
ambassadorship to the European Union he
was center to the plot and he said
everyone was in a suggestion that we
were engaged in some irregular or rogue
diplomacy is absolutely false the
leadership of the State Department the
National Security Council and the White
House were all informed about the
Ukraine efforts and another State
Department official testified he heard
sunland on the phone with the president
during the lunch Ambassador silence said
that he was gonna call president Trump
to give it an update master silent
placed a call on his mobile phone
I heard him announce himself several
times along the lines of Gordon song
land holding for the president I then
heard president Trump ask so he's going
to do the investigation
ambassador songline replied that he's
going to do it adding that President
Solinsky will do anything you ask him to
do with that Democrats say they've made
the case for two counts of impeachment
one for abuse of power the second for
obstruction of Congress voters know the
vote out of the commitment split down
party lines with Republicans launching
varying defenses to key facts have not
changed that are critical to these
impeachment proceedings one Ukraine in
fact received the aid and two there was
no investigation into the Biden sment I
have never in my entire life seen such
an unfair
rigged railroad job against the
President of the United States and threw
it on the president remained defiant
it's a witch hunt
it's a sham it's a hoax a slight
majority of Americans polled actually
support impeachment and removal but not
by much and as of now the vote is
expected to be partisan which would
leave Trump in office that could change
if public opinion does during the trial
setting up a high-stakes gamble that
will impact the president the country
and the world
patty Cal hain al Jazeera Washington